yes you're at that right I am going on a
break don't worry though there will
still be videos just not as many I've
decided to basically reduce the upload
frequency a little bit mostly because I
am going on a break but also because I
kind of want to have time to do other
things but we'll get to that later so
how's our little channel doing we've
just passed 1 million views 1 million
times someone thought well that's kind
of worth watching and only about 900,000
times where they were severely
disappointed after clicking on the video
I think that's the thing that's a net
gain honestly the channel just surpassed
30 thousand subscribers so technically
in log space were already halfway to a
hundred thousand matter of time and I
think I've said this in the last update
but this is just absolutely overwhelming
how many people are interested in
machine learning research and topics
related to it so that's pretty cool and
encouraging thank you everyone who has
already subscribed and especially the
people that leave comments the people
that share the videos this means a lot
and I think it's awesome and it's quite
motivating to continue doing this
honestly I'm having lots of fun along
with that I've gained almost 5,000
Twitter followers I think more than
5,000 Twitter followers which is strange
because Twitter is weird but you know so
that's pretty cool I guess I wonder if
all of those are subscribed to the
channel in any case I just want to
highlight again that the community
around machine learning research is in
the absolute largest part a very very
positive community you people are
absolutely great the comment sections
are just so much better than anything
else on the entire internet including
paper reviews at major conferences
really this is a half joke that the
comments section is better than the
reviews on papers but it is actually
very often true people
are discussing ideas in the comments
that are valuable and creative and
asking interesting questions and helping
each other out and that also counts for
our discord server so if you're not on
our discord server we do have one and
there is a channel for beginners
question there's a channel for
discussing the videos that are on the
YouTube channel and people are generally
very very helpful there it's a vibrant
community and I can only recommend that
if you are looking to contribute to the
community and be part of it it's a great
place that being said I'm also on a
number of other platforms such as
LinkedIn I finally made a LinkedIn
account
I was always kind of skeptic I don't
know how LinkedIn works like what is the
difference between follow and connect
and then people like write little
messages while connecting and it says
like I'd love to connect but then you
accept them and then that message pops
up and then it's saying I loved I'd love
to connect but you've already connected
at that point I this is we like how does
LinkedIn works tell me what is it for
like I get it it's like professional
social networking but ah it seems weird
to me okay but there is an entire
community there and I do post my videos
there I'm not like super active on
LinkedIn I have to say that I'm also on
shoot mines parlor so the reason
why I'm mentioning these things is that
with recent developments especially
around this young looking video there
were some developments that potentially
threaten the existence of this channel
and I don't want to make it a single
point of failure so I would appreciate
it if you follow me on at least one
other thing at least one other point of
contact so that in the case that
something might happen which is unlikely
but you know can I still have a way of
distributing this content all the links
are in the video description I'd love to
see you there wherever so with respect
to the young
situation he has left Twitter now de
facto and and people wanted me to kind
of make a follow-up video asked me about
it
but I feel you know I I have I have
nothing more substantial to say and just
to make a video for video sake it's not
really a thing I want to go into general
it's kind of sad but these kind of news
and drama videos they do get a lot of
attention not like outrages but they do
get I want to keep this channel mostly
about the machine learning research and
I only want to make videos when I really
do have some information to add you know
Young Lacan is an adult and he's able to
make his decisions of whether he wants
to leave Twitter or not it's probably
for the better for his mental health so
with respect to the drama videos I
always kind of say that I'll pull you in
with the drama and then before you know
it I educate you ha checkmate so that's
how this works and how we ultimately end
up with many more machine learners then
originally wanted to be we gotcha so in
other news flatland round one of
flatland has officially started and I've
previously made a video about flatland
it is a new rips challenge it is a
challenge where we have to route trains
around a a 2d map and I wanted to make
this kind of a community project where
we do research together hopefully do
something with machine learning with
reinforcement learning to tackle this
problem and to crush the challenge and
this is looking extremely good so on our
discord server there is a core group of
people that is really engaged and this
is one of the reasons why I kind of want
to reduce my upload frequency because I
want to have time to participate more in
these community efforts I really want to
have time to do more myself in the
flatland research group that we have we
do open research anyone is welcome
you're still very welcome join our
discord server and join us and
contribute to the code there is a core
group right now that is really pushing
forward so just to highlight a few of
them there is no
édouard direct Dola frostbite China CEO
trademarked AI Adrian and I'm Peter and
I forgot nuber pwnage am so sorry noob
apology
you're beautiful these people are
helping each other reach more and better
performance profiling code implementing
parts from other papers and it's just
great to see that people can collaborate
on this even though it's technically a
competition but you know I guess we're
competing against nature for anyone I
haven't mentioned here I'm very very
sorry and any list of names is always
prone to leave people out I do not want
to diminish your impact so right now
this D queuing algorithm is able to
reach about a 95% success rate with
three to five agents on the maps of
three to five trains but round one has
just started and we see that some of
these environments have many many more
agents in them so there's still a lot of
work to do so we need you to come and
contribute and join the fun it is fun
and as I said I will be working on this
myself or as well because it's fun so
again big shout out to anyone on this
court that has contributed in any way
this is just awesome
we've just had a recently our first
grassland Town Hall with entirely
community generated content so these
people came together and basically
joined in making one PowerPoint
presentation and then presented to each
other their knowledge of the environment
and amazingly we also had the flatland
organizers come in and tell us their
perspective about the challenge the
environment and what's challenging and
what's changed and so on this was just
unprecedented for me the amount of
contributions there the first town hall
is available if you join this court it's
linked there it's recorded you can still
see it and
as I said there's still plenty of time
to join the competition together with us
okay next thing you've probably seen the
spine net video and the thumbnail there
was excessively beautiful so the story
behind it is on the discord server I've
asked people to help me with this some
nail which was originally rather boring
and I just kind of wanted to know which
subtitle I should put there and then one
of the discord members Lucas Ferrara
just gone ahead and drawn up this very
beautiful image of a spine net robot
that has the spine net as a spine and
this is this kind of stuff is just
awesome so again big shout out to Lucas
Ferrara and the absolutely amazing
thumbnail that this has generated and
also the contributions to anyone that
comes on the discord server and into the
beginners question channel ask some
question and usually get some form of
help now that being said please do don't
just come and we'll solve your problem
like try to search for a solution before
going into that group of very
well-meaning people because you know if
if too many people just expect them to
solve their problems it won't be as
well-meaning anymore in the future okay
so how does this channel go forward I
want to make the content a bit more
diverse and kind of branch out and as I
already said the upload frequency will
be sort of lower after my break or also
during my break but I have some ideas of
how to generate kind of more interesting
content or different content so here are
my ideas and this is a list and please
tell me what you think of it and you can
do this at this video and you can do
this at any point you can give feedback
about what kind of videos you like what
kind of style of videos you like
anything really I'm happy to listen to
people and incorporate all the feedback
that I can
so I want to do some more channel
updates maybe more frequently maybe once
every two three weeks just to let you
know what's going on kind of what's
going on with the channel what's going
on with the community this should be fun
so another idea I had is to look at kind
of historical papers and I think I got
the idea from a comment in my comment
section so shout out to whoever lifted
me to that it's a great idea to
basically go back to historical papers
and just kind of see what people back
then knew and didn't know and predicted
and were right about and especially I
wonder what kind of choices did they
make that survived until this day kind
of arbitrary choices that someone made
in some paper that just stuck around
it's interesting to see and there will
be a series of kind of classical papers
that I will extend from time to time and
I hope you enjoy that I also want to do
more a bit of live coding videos lots of
people have requested that I'm not the
best coder in the world but I have done
my fair share of machine learning
research hands on I have lots of more
stupid ideas that might or might not
work out and I'm very happy to implement
them live then next thing I want to
branch out in topics maybe more exotic
things causality is a big thing quantum
machine learning what not more practical
applications robotics control also
fairness a lot of people especially
after the young lock on video asked me
to look more into the fairness
literature I am naturally very
interested in that and approach it from
kind of a a technical but also a
societal standpoint throughout all of
that I would like to include the
community more so you I don't really
know how to do that properly yet so
here's the first thing that I'm going to
include you if you have a good idea of
how to do more community inclusion in
the channels content please tell me
because I think the community has lots
of stuff to give and it would be a shame
if it were only me always doing all the
things where other people would be much
better at it okay the last question on
this
is a question that I get very often and
that is how do I select papers and there
seems to be of a misconception in this
so let me tell you I select papers by
what interests me and that alone if I
make a video about a paper it means that
I found it interesting enough to read it
and I found it interesting enough to
make a video about it now this can be
accelerated by sending me appropriate
amounts of protein and carbohydrates but
generally me making a video is not an
endorsement of a paper it doesn't mean
that this paper is the most important
paper or influential it doesn't mean
anything beyond I find it interesting if
I ever get sponsor deals I'll let you
know that a video is sponsored and
that's that I will not change how I
select papers I will not go by some kind
of impact I would like to branch out my
content I see the danger and only kind
of covering what the big companies do
but honestly they do a lot of
interesting stuff they do a lot of stuff
and I'm constantly looking at research
that's kind of outside the box
whatever is interesting you know that's
what it's gonna be I will not start
going by some impact factor and I will
not start politicizing my paper review
selection any time soon you know I've
already had multiple people high profile
people come to me and say well with your
platform couldn't you once a week take a
paper where the first author is an
underrepresented minority and review
that and you know I appreciate the
sentiment behind it and I see I see
where it comes from but if you consider
the practical implications of something
like this like I
I'd have to you know go through papers
Google the first author kind of try to
find a talk or a picture of them and an
estimate whether the melanin content in
their skin is high enough for this to
qualify now and something like this and
just the thought of this how someone
could do something like this and know
start to vomit is just beyond me I don't
know what to say other than that so let
me say this if you're thinking leads you
to a place where it's necessary to treat
people differently based on the color of
their skin
you're wrong like that's my opinion
but you're wrong the answer to bias
cannot consist of more bias that's that
I do not care how the person that wrote
a paper looks like if your papers on
this channel it means your work was
interesting to me and I hope that can be
my contribution to making the community
more fair and just okay last thing lots
of people have asked me if I had a
patreon or something like this and I've
sort of resisted that kind of stuff
until now mainly because I knew that the
day would come when I reduce my upload
frequency and I didn't want to kind of
trick people into thinking that I was
going to continue this forever again
financial support is not my main goal
here and it is completely absolutely and
utterly voluntary and so I just want to
have that out there so I have made a
patreon page I do have some reservation
with respect to patreon because of free
speech issues and so on so I've also
made a SUBSCRIBE start page both are
equal both have equal tiers all the
tiers are equal there is no option we're
just we're you could just put an amount
which I would like so I just tried to
make a bunch of tiers all of them are
equal so I have to ask myself what do I
give as a benefit because I don't want
someone to have to pay for like extra
content because the entire goal of this
channel is to educate people including
people that don't have money to go to
good universities that might live in
other parts of the world where education
is not as available where resources are
not as available to give extra content
to people that pay seems to be so I
thought okay what I could give to the
well that do support me on these pages
is you will get a PDF of my scribbled
OneNote document of the papers that our
review I mean it's not very helpful
because I mostly scribble and it's going
to be like subdividing the pages weirdly
maybe it has more of a symbolic value
and if if you're really into that in you
know at least there's something I've
also made a bunch of crypto wallets so
if you'd rather want to use that to
support me you are welcome to do so all
the links are in the description of the
video again financial support very very
very optional and very voluntary though
of course I do thank anyone that does I
am also going to experiment with ads on
the videos and as creators we have kind
of different options of which ads are
displayed and how often and so on I
found mid video ads annoying I find
nonce capable ads annoying and so on I'm
really counting on you here to give me
feedback after various videos of how
much the ads and all you which ones
annoy you which ones don't
I'm really counting on you okay okay
last thing I am planning planning on a
line of merch mainly because I think
it's funny but I don't know if that's
gonna work out but you know maybe if you
have fun t-shirt ideas or so just let me
know alright that was the update as I
said I probably won't be reading
comments too much but I will catch up
after the break and I hope you continue
enjoying this channel even with kind of
the lower upload frequency and the new
types of content that come in if you do
have suggestions for new exotic content
that have a Glee has to do with machine
learning or not let me know let me know
what you think of anything I said and I
wish you an awesome summer and I hope to
see you here anytime
ciao